[Music]
hey
look look who's with us on the show
that's why i didn't put the ticker on so
you could see her better because i
thought that ticker would cover
her up in here well she tried to come up
on the desk and then
she was like she was eyeing the the
laptop she's like oh
i could sit on that yeah and i was like
no please
so i had to pick her up and put her on
daddy's lap
and she's actually being really good
yeah normally she would just jump right
off like [ __ ] this
yeah she's she she's kind of relaxed
right now for some reason oh hi
girl yeah you being relaxed yeah you're
so sweet
yeah bee's nest did you just get i just
sent you on facebook i just sent you
tom's
uh his uh profile yeah
you should already have that dude i
don't know why you're running over the
same old ground over and over again
anyway we just got done uh cutting a big
long as an
hour and a half long well almost an hour
and a half yeah almost hour and a half
long
a review of the apocalypse now redux
yeah that um one of y'all sent us we had
all this [ __ ] written down who sent us
what
and somehow we lost that that well yeah
i kind of got so i don't know i think i
might have been louie that sent that to
me well like i said it's
either louie michael e or
sophie stuff or sophie sends me stuff
yeah it's it's usually one of those
yeah it's usually one of those four
people and it's like i said i feel kind
of bad because sometimes i can't
remember because i do write stuff down
but then like [ __ ] ends up getting
thrown out and like scraps of paper and
yeah
we had a big we had a big
shipment of for some reason a bunch of
them all came in at once
yeah remember that yeah it was like a
week there was like a two or three week
period where we got about
20 of them louie said yes sir that was
me yeah that was good [ __ ]
man that was that was [ __ ] bad i
hadn't seen that since i was a teenager
and actually i never i've never seen
that
i've never seen the redux version so i
thought that was cool i'd only seen the
theatrical guy i've never seen it on
blu-ray
i'd only seen it on vhs yeah and man the
difference is [ __ ] huge
it's a huge difference well honestly for
the final cut which they released
in 2019 they re-released in 2019
um which is like 20 minutes shorter than
the redux version they actually
like went through and cleaned it up yeah
like frame by frame
not for the blu-ray one but for the
final cut one
so i guess if it comes out it'll be like
the ultimate version louie uh
we got into it man about an hour and a
half i brought up a lot of parallels
between conan
you know because it's amelia's story
john millions wrote that and there's a
lot of the same themes
i don't know if you picked them up but
you probably did knowing conan
knowing that story yeah i think it'll be
a good review there's a lot of meaning
you know behind stuff
and fit it's not 100 accurate you know
i had platoon sergeants and squad
leaders
that served in those units during the
vietnam
theater my first sergeant in 506 for
first sergeant richardson
went up and down hamburger hill three
times
in about a 24 hour period and it was him
and only two or three other guys from
that platoon that lived
and he had pictures to prove it in his
pocket he had a picture of the whole
platoon
laid out dead on the flight line to be
flown out
yeah he kept in his pocket remember
remember him but
um his whole platoon got wiped out there
yeah and
uh we had uh a couple of uh
squad leaders that were they were old
squad leaders by then they were [ __ ]
damn near pushing 50 back then but they
were still around
i they improve they probably weren't
that old probably late 40s
mid late 40s and um
so a lot of vietnam stories you know
from guys that were in our units
it's not like what you what you heard a
lot and it's not a hundred percent like
you saw in apocalypse now the the ship
was run a lot tighter
um it was a lot more by the numbers by
the book
but a lot of what you see in apocalypse
now was spiritually true
if you know what i mean a lot of stuff
they were doing was stuff that they
wished they could do
like they wished they could ski off the
back of the patrol boat you couldn't
actually
get away with it though yeah i mean
which is coming out thursday if you're a
patron or friday if you're not a patron
so you'll be able to see that like yeah
we went on like i think it was an hour
and 15 minutes hour and 20 minutes
something like that
there's a lot to talk about you know
there's a lot to talk about there's a
lot of interesting stuff
in there both factual and um
um yeah i see a book and it
came from stuff and kind of like
mythological and mythical there's a lot
of mythicism in it
yeah like just like uh conan one
yeah yeah so this movie we ended up this
okay this is really weird how we ended
up watching this because basically i
told tom i was like
okay well we have to watch another kind
of newish one so
let's check amazon prime and see what
the [ __ ] is up there so we started
scrolling through there and it's like we
saw a couple there was like a korean one
that's out of bed
that's a possibility maybe that one's
good and then we get to the end and we
find this movie
which on amazon prime it's called the
13th locker
and it says that it came out in 2020
right
yeah and we read the little description
and it's like it's an anthology and i'm
like ooh my little ears perked up
because i'm kind of like oh i like
anthology movies and they said it's kind
of in the vein of you know suspense or
the twilight zone
and i was like oh that sounds pretty
good so we watched it and we enjoyed it
but then like when i was
doing research i found out that the
movie is actually called
locker 13 which i thought from the title
card too i'm like that looks like locker
13 not the 13th locker but whatever
and it actually came out in 2014 not
2020.
so i don't know why that mistake is like
that must have been re-released
maybe and the thing about it too is that
i think that the all the directors
because i think there are like five or
six directors on this uh because it's
like i said it's an anthology
i think they had been working on it
since 2009
like they had a kickstarter they made
the first uh story the one about the
boxer
and that was kind of like what they
showed to people like on their
kickstarter page like to get money
yeah so they ended up getting money but
it took them like five years to make it
had ricky schroeder in it
yeah had a bunch of uh i would call them
c and d list celebrities well it's only
it had so many everybody that's in this
time ago you you recognized you're like
hey it's that guy
he's like yeah yeah
they all did a great they're all fat
guys at this movie yeah yeah
oh that guy yeah they were all like the
supporting
character actors that you remember from
a while back you know
uh they're probably guys that would work
cheap but they did a great job they did
a great job
it's kind of like a twilight zone it is
kind of like a bunch of twilight zone
episodes yeah
it's kind of like yeah this even had
curtis armstrong in it because
he was in the second segment i was like
hey it's booger from revenge of the
nerds yeah but um
so it's like a lot of [ __ ] like that but
so it's weird because
it seems like this movie
got like really really bad reviews
except on horror sites it seemed like a
lot of horror sites seemed to
kind of dig it um but a lot of other
kind of sites were just like nah they
just thought it was dumb or whatever but
um i don't know i thought it was like
pretty entertaining
so basically or the horror fans are a
little bit more forgiving because it's
like oh it's another one
it's another anthology and i think a lot
of and i think a lot of horror fans
are like me and they like it it's just a
new it's just another anthology it's
pretty good and it was kind of cool that
that it went more for like a twilight
zoney type of
vibe and like a creep show type of vibe
you know what i mean not that i don't
love creep show and
[ __ ] yeah it's definitely twilight zone
it is very twilight zoney
um so yeah so here's what it is now the
wrap-around story
which has uh the guy
man the dude that play that's uh playing
the [ __ ]
um archie the guy that's trained in the
other guy at the old west park or
whatever
that dude i mean i remembered him i
think the first time i saw him was i
think that was him that was in ferris
bueller's day off he was like the guy
that
was parking the car and you know ferris
was like uh
you know do you speak english and he's
like what country do you think this is i
think it's that guy but he's been liking
a [ __ ] ton of other
[ __ ] too so you open on this old west
theme park it's essentially like a
tombstone
you know like they have tourists coming
there like [ __ ] disneyland or
whatever
and so he's there training a night
janitor person
named skip who has just gotten out of
prison for something does he ever say
what he got out of prison for
i don't think he does i think he kind of
like evades the question
so he's training him for this job and
while he's kind of walking him around to
give him a tour
he sort of tells him the stories
um and all of the stories are not really
related other than that they all
feature a locker like locker 13
right that's the only thing that ties
them all together
so the first story ricky schroeder is in
it who i recognized immediately
i was like hey it's rookie shredder and
he plays kind of this aging like over
the hill boxer
and he's just like kind of getting his
ass beat all the time
um and his even his manager is just kind
of like bro
it's over you know what i mean you got
to spoil these are you no i'm not going
to
i'm just going to kind of set it up that
was a good one and it was very simple
yeah and it was that was probably the
most twilight zone i don't know it's
hard to say that it definitely wasn't
yeah it was quite yeah it was a little
bit short for a twilight zone
it was very short but uh that's like
something that they would have done yeah
yeah they would have expounded on it
yeah that evidently that was that was
the demo they used to fund the rest of
the
yeah that was the first one yeah so it
was like the shortest one like to get
kickstarter money
so yeah so he's like this washed up
boxer and
then this kind of mysterious janitor
i don't know who that dude was gives him
a pair of these gloves and suddenly [ __ ]
starts
yeah he beat anybody's ass for these
gloves
sometimes uh more than beat their ass so
yeah so
like i said this is a very short story
very simple um these are all just kind
of like short almost like little
morality plays just like twilight zone
ones
so yeah so then there's that one then
the second one
which is probably like the funniest one
was called uh
the byzantine order this is actually i
think my favorite one
i think i liked this one the best too
it's a this one was like the weirdest
one
it was for whatever reason it was set
like back in the 1920s i guess
like just from the slang and everything
yeah it's a fraternal order kind of like
the shriners or something with their
crazy fans they're called the benevolent
byzantine order of the nobles of the
enigmatic oracle
that's what they're called this is the
one that has booger in it
yeah and then it got the old guy that
always used to show up in the old movies
he's always the old wise guy
i don't know what his name that actually
well and that guy the the old guy that
was in the wheelchair yeah that was the
dude that was
lebowski from the big lebowski okay yeah
yeah yeah
that's good because you were like man
i've seen that i could place him but
then later i thought of it
yeah it's that guy okay i was like well
i kept calling him
cheney because he kind of yeah he's like
dick cheese he looks a little bit like
dick cheese
yeah but yeah so basically this one set
in the 1920s it's set in this kind of
like fraternal order type of thing with
all their little fuzzes and whatnot
and there's this guy named uh
eugene and he's supposed to be the new
recruit right yeah so he's not really
sure what he's getting in for
he's like getting paddled he's scared
he's gonna get paddled or
maybe sacrificed or who knows what the
hell is going on
and then there's like kind of a plot
twist with the burlesque dancer that
they hire
yeah who pops out of the cake and with
her baby in there
like all of a sudden they kind of make
it it's oh i don't know
that one was like probably the funniest
one and then
uh the third one is called suicide club
this is probably the weakest one it was
all right
um because it was mostly just it was
this dude and he was going to jump off a
building right i was getting pretty
inebriated by this point yeah but um
he's going to jump off a building and
then suddenly this dude turns up
who's from uh the suicide club and he's
basically like man don't do it like that
you got to do he's giving him like
pointers on like how to kill kill
himself so it was kind of like a cool
concept but it's basically just like two
guys on a roof like talking to each
other
um you know so i'd see that was probably
but that was an okay one too
um and then the last one or the last one
other than the wrap around and we say
it's okay the performances are
pretty good in all of you yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's great it's the writing
it's you know it could have been a
little bit more but you know like i said
some of those twilight zone episodes
there wasn't a whole lot to them either
but you know yeah it was it was
entertaining yeah
yeah and then uh then the last one
except for the end of the wrap around
was called the author and this one was
basically i think we were talking and so
i missed like the setup of the beginning
but what it what it was is that there's
a dude
who i guess he was like a hit man and he
supposedly had killed this guy and then
he kidnapped
this guy's three mistresses and chained
him to a wall
and then he was trying to figure out
which one of them hired him to kill the
dude
you know what i mean yeah so that so
there was that whole thing that one was
pretty good but like i said i missed a
lot of the setup and i had to like look
it up later like what because i was like
wait why are these girls chained to the
wall and he's like
you don't need to kill him i don't get
pretty loaded but
yeah that's kind of overpoured yeah a
little bit
yeah i mean i was kind of losing track
of some of that i mean i remember
well and plus we were having a
conversation think
we were talking about something it's
probably hormones yeah we were talking
about hormones
and so we missed like the beginning of
the part so i only saw like the second
half of this
a lot of people kind of um got all over
uh
the dude that was playing the hitman and
he
how he's like a fake cuban accent and
like they were wondering why he made
that decision but whatever
um so then you get like the end of the
wrap around
and actually i really liked this because
it went in a direction i didn't expect
so like i said the wrap around is the
dude archie and he's training
skip to be like the nighttime janitor at
this like old west
theme parky type attraction
so what ends up happening is that
skip um you know archie has told him hey
you know stay away from my locker which
is locker thirteen don't even clean it
like don't even touch it with the thing
so it's all like gross and dirty and
everything
so of course skip is like i'm gonna
check that [ __ ] out
i wanna see what's going on back there
because it's supposed this big like he
hears like noises coming from in there
and [ __ ]
and then he opens it and it's um
basically he sees
himself in there but it's himself
from like a day ahead or a day behind i
forgot i can't remember yeah
it was yeah so it's so it's like another
like an alternate dimension version of
him
and he's like talking so of course
they're like hey we can like do the
lottery and because i have tomorrow's
lottery numbers and all this other kind
of [ __ ] but of course it doesn't work
out the way
that you think it's gonna work out um
because so i
so i kind of liked that it went in that
weird like supernaturally kind of
direction because i wasn't really
expecting that
um so yeah this was a pretty solid
anthology i feel like i i was
entertained
yeah um you know i i don't know there's
nothing to complain about
not really and and that's the thing it's
it's seemed very strange to me that when
this came out because like i said i
thought it was recent i thought it was
from this year but it's actually from
like six years ago
but it seemed like when it came out six
years ago like a lot of people really
were just like man or they just like
didn't like it because they were spoiled
back then
maybe it's like it's you know it's like
they were given
like one or two stars and i'm like i
don't get i thought it was perfectly
good
and then like i said i found a couple
horror sites though that gave it
like you know seventy-five percent gave
it on there and [ __ ] gave it one star
yeah maybe i don't know i heard that
people bomb each other's products all
the time
yeah people are petty like people yeah
they probably do they're like i hate
that [ __ ] man go ahead
we're all going we're all gonna go and
bomb that movie it's like the crew off
another movie
yeah you know what i mean we heard they
did that we have to torpedo that movie
so our movie will be
remember that one that we saw so [ __ ]
there was one of those [ __ ] crappy
movies that we saw
and it had like it it had been out for
about a week and it had about 20 ratings
and they were all [ __ ] five star
ratings
it turns out it was everybody on the
demo well that's everybody on the crew
and like their relatives
well because everybody does that they
always kind of like hey mom go and write
like a good review of my movie it's like
you don't even have to watch it just say
it's the most awesome thing you ever saw
that's terrible that wasn't the one
about the clowns was it
oh man oh no i can't remember remember
that was clown fear
yeah i think it was it was clowns the
one before
the only thing i liked about clown fear
was that clown motel
because i was like is that a real place
if it's not a real place then they did a
really good job of like set dressing it
although i almost kind of hope it's a
real place it was just some kind of
clown figure i think i think that was
the one that had all the fake ratings on
it
yeah maybe but that's pr i mean i
imagine that's pretty widespread and
like i said if you're
a little indie filmmaker and you made a
movie with your friends all your kids
a few thousand bucks yeah then i mean
you
that's just what you would do i mean you
would get all your friends and family to
go on there and talk about how cool your
[ __ ] is well no i'm just saying a lot of
people do
is at least get somebody that can write
a script well yeah what you would do is
like make a good movie
it all happens that's harder than it
seems like it all
happens in the writing phase if the
story isn't there
the movie isn't gonna be there don't
[ __ ] make the movie until the [ __ ]
script is good
yeah because writers like writers
yes we are at the we are at the heart of
all of the entertainment
writers yes all those bad ass movies
like apocalypse now we just talked about
it wasn't francis ford coppola it was
[ __ ] john nillie's the writer
yeah you know even though a lot of it
got cut out it still didn't matter the
story was there
and [ __ ] millions was like yeah
that's it that's the story yeah
so you know louie's the writer yeah
i mean like i said everything starts
with it yeah if you don't have that
right you're not going to have a good
anything no that's that's
and here's something right down to it
when i say good writers
there are writers that are good that
aren't good for certain things all right
there's
there's
yeah everyone has their strengths
strengths and weaknesses yes
like [ __ ] man what's a good ex
okay ryan johnson [ __ ]
you don't want that [ __ ] on star
wars but knives out was great
i liked it i loved knives that was
really good all right
because you can tell that that was the
kind of movie he was right he just
he was not the he's good director and i
guess he writes too
all right he's good it's just he's not
good for star wars
yeah he's just and like i said some
people are just not suited yeah he was
the wrong guy and i mean i didn't hate
that movie as much as a lot of people
did but
i can see how they maybe should have got
somebody who he tried to read the
wheelhouse
he tried to reboot a [ __ ] established
franchise and subvert and do
tricky artistic things with something
that is essentially a [ __ ]
traditional comfort movie
yeah you're not supposed to do that you
know it's like that's
i can see why people would want to do
that because particularly people that
are really artistic they're like man i
don't want to do the same thing
and i don't want to do what people
expect that's so boring it's like i get
it
you know i do get that because i'm the
same that's not what star wars was i
know
but that's that's the thing that's why
the mandalorian works if they gave me
star wars i would probably have done the
same thing but i'd be like man this is
so boring i'm just like i need to like
shake this up
that's wrong just to entertain myself
wrong move for star wars
that's why the mandalorian works is
because the mandalorian is what star
wars is
a [ __ ] western and a samurai and a
samurai at the same time
yeah they really captured the essence
that's what it is right and a world war
ii movie
yeah right well at least the the big
trilogy movies
was a world war ii movie that was a
cowboy movie and a samurai movie at once
yeah yeah it's a hodgepodge but they
made it work
but you know what lucas didn't really
have a whole lot to do with that that
was in edit
and then [ __ ] empire strikes back
really lucas wasn't
was more like advising yeah but who was
that dude that did that one it was the
same director that did
uh i think robocop 2. yeah [ __ ] i can't
remember
robocop 2 is good too i like that one
yeah i'm laughing at louie saying are
you drunk no i just over poured
yeah tom ross 2021 yeah just kind of
overpoured
yeah louie also said looper is good
which i think
ryan johnson directed that i i still
haven't seen that but i really want to i
really want to see that he's good
he's good i kind of feel bad for him
that he got [ __ ] on so badly
uh for star wars but i agree he did not
handle star wars the right way
but he's not a badass he's not a bad
director
he's a good director well he's got to be
on a right project
yeah and like i said that's true of any
artistic person it's
it's kind of like it would be kind of
like if somebody gave me
you know a hundred thousand dollars and
said hey write this romantic comedy
it would be terrible i'm telling you
that right now yeah i do not i am
i am not into romantic comedy i'm not
and i just wouldn't even know
how to approach it now if you came to me
and gave me a hundred thousand dollars
to write me a badass horror movie okay i
can do that
but yeah and you don't want to put john
millius on a [ __ ] romance move
you want john millions on a [ __ ] war
movie
war movies and warrior movies and
fighting and
[ __ ] and because westerns he's super
he's super into western yes
in his interviews will not shy away he
goes you have to understand
i'm a warlike person he just comes out
and says i'm a very warlike person
you know and uh but he's looking at it
from a different way
not the corporate warfare the spiritual
warfare
internal war war from the first person
and getting beyond it motherfucker's got
ptsd he's got to
understand pat said irving kirschner is
who you're thinking of about the star
wars yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what i know i'm sitting there
going to the akk yeah yeah that's right
starts with a k because uh i think i
think pretty much everybody agrees that
empire strikes was back was um
the best of all those movies that one
was really the best one
even though i i liked all the original
i like the original trilogy all of them
especially kind of like
the first re-edit of return of the jedi
when they got
changed to the ewok soundtracks and
changed a little bit they said man the
ewoks were too [ __ ] silly in the
original cut
there was so cute silly [ __ ] man
you know what [ __ ] teddy lucas can
not
shy away from silly [ __ ] [ __ ] robots
see through pio falling into the [ __ ]
sand head first defeat it's just
childish laughs give me that edit i can
change that [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean
even though yeah the the best [ __ ]
star wars movie it was empire strikes
back i believe well like i said i don't
think anyone's going to argue
uh mango said big wednesday is a great
film by john millius
yeah i don't know that one yeah so yeah
that's another one he made he made one
called rough rider
rough riders as well i haven't seen that
one that was maybe from i want to say
2010 2011 something like that i think
it's a western
i got to see the dirty harry movies
again i haven't seen this didn't he do i
think he did the first time i think he
did the first two
i think if i remember i had to go back
later or he wrote him i don't think he
didn't direct him i don't think
no he does he does direct movies too but
i don't know yeah
um those ones were just kind of
that he wrote as far as i know
pat says at least they're better than
porgs ewoks
the problem with the new ones is that it
was too much
try hard we're gonna make a new thing
and it's gonna sell all kinds of [ __ ]
plushies
gonna be a poor we're going to make a
new thing and then they they tried
too hard to make a new thing you cannot
make a cultural phenomenon
cultural phenomenons happen
spontaneously
they're not really that predictable and
the porg is a good
example of how we're going to make a
cultural phenomenon no you're not
no you're not yeah they were trying to
do like the minions yeah despicable me i
guess
which that really took off but i guess
they didn't really i think
maybe bb8 could have been something like
that
maybe had
the other two movies panned out the
first
force awakens movie wasn't perfect
it but i saw it as them trying to
reestablish
the franchise and it wasn't bad i liked
it the first couple of times i saw it
it's just that in retrospect after the
other ones
it's like the second movie shot on the
first movie so why watch the first movie
because it reversed all that [ __ ] anyway
yeah yeah i mean so
what and and then they they just [ __ ]
man disney man
disney just can't do anything i i don't
know what's wrong with that corporation
uh well i get i take that back the
[ __ ] mandalorian watch them [ __ ]
mandalorian up
watch it well the thing about it is that
you're not seeing the same teams working
yeah that's not the same team it's not
right yeah it's not like one big right
it's not one person it's like
like lots of little sub like for
instance let's make sure
we got lots of diversity with women and
we're gonna have a black character and
everything he's gonna be great
he's gonna be a storm trooper but he's
gonna be a janitor
what the [ __ ] is this all about you know
and he's not gonna get the girl
it's just like if you're gonna have him
[ __ ] in there commit do it
he should not have been a [ __ ]
cowardly
storm trooper janitor who's run away
from the empire that
kind of [ __ ] is that you should have
[ __ ] been a badass
commando [ __ ] storm trooper
that somehow had to leave you know what
i mean he should have had an honorable
way
and then realizes that really he
shouldn't have been there or it turns
out
he had he was a jedi didn't know it he
was a jedi that got
or a young jedi padawan that got
brainwashed
or mind wiped or something like that but
he remembered the force awakened in him
some [ __ ] like that i could have come up
with a better some [ __ ] like that yeah i
could have come up with a much better
version of [ __ ] finn i could have
come up with a bunch
they [ __ ] that character up i feel bad
for john boyega
because he he he was it was gonna be
good
but they the writing they just [ __ ] it
up louis said there's a good documentary
on milius on netflix i think
or maybe amazon prime yeah i might have
to look that up check it out
yeah all right
let's check that one out john milius was
the spiritual advisor on lone wolf
mcquaid
he was no no get the [ __ ] out of here
next you gonna tell me he was [ __ ]
working with [ __ ] steven seagal
imagine that [ __ ] imagine [ __ ] imagine
john millius
trying to write a cigar flick and
directing seagal and seagal getting in
trying to get into a pissing match you
know on my films i'm the law
yeah john millions i could totally pull
out that [ __ ] 44 magnum
he carried a [ __ ] 1911. a lot of you
i don't know if you guys know this but
[ __ ]
when milius when he'd be negotiating
with hollywood executives he'd be in
their offices you know
and he was just totally cut from a
different [ __ ] cloth
you know and uh he'd start negotiating
stuff and while he's talking to
the [ __ ] studio exec he'd pull out
that [ __ ] 1911 and put it on a table
and [ __ ]
light a cigarette and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] making [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then they said what the [ __ ]
but they get 45 on a table to discuss
business and [ __ ]
[ __ ] was a trip louie said
seriously he was
what's that he was the spiritual advisor
although the show you were joking the
[ __ ] you were saying about steven seagal
like what you said like in steven
seagal's voice i could totally
it would not shock me in the least
imaginative oh do you think that steven
segal said something like that
well he said that to [ __ ] john
leguizamo and then [ __ ] hit him in
the throat and punched him and
he's just you know when i'm on a set
what i say is law
yeah and it wasn't his movie it was
somebody else's movie
he's such a team yeah it's a [ __ ]
douchebag
but imagine him saying that [ __ ] to
fuckabilius
you gotta understand something john
you're on my when i'm on set what i say
is law what can
really just shoot his face off okay
sorry i didn't go ariel sharon on his
ass
mango said seagull was born from a john
millius toenail cutting
yeah that's pretty [ __ ]
okay let me rephrase all this [ __ ]
because i don't want that [ __ ]
coming after me
all right even as fast as he is they're
gonna have to lock me up if that
[ __ ] comes after me
i hang a whole bag but i'll tell you one
thing
the amazing man that [ __ ] seagal is
is as amazing as he is
i don't think emilius would have put up
with that [ __ ]
well and and nor would anyone in their
right mind
i mean millions would have done
something to [ __ ] him over yeah and i
think a lot of people did things to
[ __ ] segal to [ __ ] him over that's
why he lives over in russia
and makes these little independent films
now you know yeah because he just pissed
so many people off because he's
insufferable
hey [ __ ] he was he showed up to one
movie that they had
and they already had pre-written
lawsuits [ __ ]
written out to [ __ ] on steven seagal
about not showing up and
not showing up to work and get [ __ ]
with people on set they already had
preset law
they're like we know how this shit's
going to go we've been this isn't our
first rodeo
they didn't file them yeah they just
[ __ ] already had them all
and they shouted to them ain't that some
[ __ ] imagine that [ __ ]
yeah that's the kind of reputation
exactly who he was
and then and then during the edit they
made sure to [ __ ] that movie up so it
didn't make any sense
and then funny that way he because they
were trying to get him out of the
business yeah
[ __ ] funny it was like his last
studio movie i mean you can't
j you just can't go around acting that
way everyone's just gonna like
he's a sociopath yeah everyone's gonna
like take [ __ ] revenge on your ass
he's not even a [ __ ] psychopath a
psychopath [ __ ]
understands the fact that don't bite the
hand that feeds you right
yeah i mean and that and a psychopath
recognizes the power other people
have over them right try it not a
sociopath sociopath [ __ ]
they're they're too disorganized they're
just winging it
and it's basically a pathological lie
basically it's a pathological liar
that's what it is yeah it's a
pathological liar
so they're acting only in the moment
there's no machiavellian plan
for success that's why they don't
succeed
yeah a high functioning psychopath can
plan and [ __ ]
you know execute a mission yeah
the only thing the only thing that the
only thing that kind of
really differentiates a high functioning
psychopath from a normal person is that
a high functioning psychopath doesn't
care about casualties
yeah that's all it is doesn't care that
other people got [ __ ] over from this
plant they don't care
that's it's like a survival of the
fittest type things well if they were
if they were worth their [ __ ] they
wouldn't have let me [ __ ] them over that
way
yeah so they deserve it yeah that's that
almost military yeah because that's kind
of the way it is pat is asking
more about more details about the steven
seagal john leguizamo face it
face off okay so what movie was it i
forgot which
i can't remember what movie they were
working on it was one it's one of
segal's last
i think it i think it might have been
segal's last studio-backed
movie yeah um john leguizamo was work uh
they were all backstage getting ready
for something not really backstage or
they were off the set
yeah i think they were in a stairwell
somewhere
and uh they were saying something the
about what the director had said and
steven seagal says you know well
director said this and then steven
seagal says
what i think he is just remember people
what i say when i'm on set what i say is
law yeah he said something to that
effect yeah and [ __ ] john like his
own [ __ ] laugh
he laughed as you would as a normal
person would because he's like he
thought he was joking
yeah yeah and [ __ ] john look is
almost about five five
yeah he's a little dude yeah and uh
[ __ ]
seagulls big that's really where his
power comes from was his size you've got
a big [ __ ] in an outfit and he
can lie you might believe him
all right yeah what is he six four yeah
he's pretty big six two six three
something like that
and [ __ ] he like he [ __ ] goes boom
like that and puts him like in a
chokehold type thing
and and and i like that and i forgot
what he said he says
you know like i am the law type of deal
i am the law
and [ __ ] look at zama was like oh why
why'd you do it why
you know and that got out that was part
of part of the end of segal was him
jumping on a little [ __ ] giant like
his ammo just for [ __ ] snickering
snickering at a very snicker worthy yeah
just like him yeah sure
yeah okay well because like i said you
would think that he was kidding
because who the [ __ ] says [ __ ] like that
unironically come on now
[Laughter]
nobody it's a god seagal doesn't have
things like
a sense of irony he really doesn't he
doesn't have any sense of humor either
no he really doesn't
he he's he was very insecure
i think executive decision executive
decision i think that's right yeah
he's very insecure with his uh set
with himself and his position i think
because
he suspects everybody knows that he
lied his way into that career yeah
and that he's kind of a fake yeah in a
lot of ways
because he's lied about a lot of [ __ ]
over the over the years that he [ __ ]
worked for the cia he
worked for the cia or no no i didn't and
then he always backs up on the [ __ ] when
they called him on it
over time but uh he's
he told a lot of [ __ ] what what does
[ __ ] gordon ramsay call him
porky's porkies he told a lot of porkies
that's pork pies that's cockney wrapping
flour yeah yeah
and kind of caught up with him over time
you know yeah he was from
befo he was from before the internet
before you can really
[ __ ] check and that you know what i
mean [ __ ]
nowadays everything people recorded of
what was said on these talk shows
ends up being saved and used against you
later he's
he's a sociopath he would just lie on on
the spot
not thinking that that [ __ ] was recorded
and then one day would resurface
as technology got better you know that
wasn't part of the plan you know
so yeah and but i gotta head it to
to [ __ ] seagull his first his first
group of movies was pretty good
for the time yeah the kill was pretty
good out for justice uh i really liked
under siege one under siege two
is kind of corny but i kind of liked it
too from what i remember but it had some
hockey [ __ ] in it but that was supposed
to
i didn't take understands too seriously
you didn't really take any of that [ __ ]
seriously really it was you know
well yeah they were just kind of fun
popcorn right
but he took that [ __ ] very soon he did
yeah which i think is
one of his problems and he would walk
around on his talk shows about you know
basically saying yeah i'd kick i could
kick that dude's ass i could kick that
dude's ass i could kick all these dudes
asses
he couldn't kick anybody's asses he'd
never been any [ __ ] fights
there's no there's no um there's no
recordings of him being in
any kind of professional fight yeah he
didn't he's not a fighter he was an
actor
yeah yeah he did it aikido yeah he was
big
that aikido shit's fake yeah it's like
fake wrestling kind of kind of fake well
he was a real akito martial artist
it's just that aikido is not all that
real
yeah well it's not really the martial
art you want if you actually do want to
kick people
yeah if you want to kick somebody's ass
you use mma
yeah mma [ __ ] cage fighting [ __ ]
it's gonna end up on the ground and a
[ __ ] bed and [ __ ] punching
[ __ ] fighting [ __ ]
[Laughter]
then that dude's like this you know he's
all [ __ ] up
stomping on that [ __ ] stomping his
[ __ ] down into a goddamn greasy spot
on the ground
that's usually how it really goes man i
used to get into those fights we just
[ __ ]
beat on each other too tired you're both
sitting down [ __ ] breathing
i'll get you in a minute
because it almost gets to the point once
you get over it where you can't really
hurt each other that badly you're too
tired
you lost all your strength and you can't
really punch hard enough anymore
neither one of you are really hurting at
each other and then everybody's watches
all right so
it's all right yeah yeah [ __ ] it give me
a cigarette
that's usually how it goes and your
[ __ ] know what i'm talking about it's
never like in the movies
pow sometimes you had you know [ __ ]
one shot
knock out [ __ ] artists and [ __ ] but
a lot of those guys that could knock you
out with one blow they were kind of just
an artist at knocking you out if
if he failed a lot of times he got his
ass beat because he just had a sweet
spot somebody yeah but he didn't have
any kind of mega endurance yeah he's
like i hadn't planned for anything
beyond this
but but uh no [ __ ]
if if you got good groundwork you can
just choke somebody out into oblivion
you you
you clearly won at that point you
clearly won
proved it yeah that's that's that's
that's usually how it goes
all right anything else you would like
to add that's about it about this
yeah so uh this movie kind of you know
i'll just
wrap it up with that uh if you like
anthology movies if you like twilight
zone type [ __ ]
check it out it's not fantastic but it's
pretty good i don't know why it's called
the 13th locker
on amazon prime uh because it's actually
called locker 13 but whatever
it's the same [ __ ] movie um all right
so first one the before
times yeah yeah yeah back when that [ __ ]
happened
back when that [ __ ] happened yeah all
right so uh
that'll do it for today i guess now
tomorrow is wednesday
which means tomorrow at 5 p.m eastern is
our midweek sidetracks party stream
woohoo gonna have the lead we don't even
know what we're going to talk about yeah
you guys will find out same time we do
yeah all right so uh thanks everybody
for coming by
and we'll see you guys tomorrow evening
bye